Today's topic. Ellen's generous. She's apologized because on her set,
there's been rumors of so much toxic behavior. All right.
And I'm not talking about the Britney Spears kind.
No, I'm talking about like that mad, toxic waste.
You know what I mean? And you're like, Ooh.
And then you turn to mutant the next day, the talk to the rapture there is,
right. So a whole bunch of allegations came out.
She was under a lot of fire. A lot of people have been saying,
Ellen is actually a total mean and horrendous person.
And so after months and months of problems going on for her,
she's made this video.
Oh boy, welcome to season 18 of the Ellen Degen show.
If you're watching, because you love me. Thank you. If you're watching,
because you don't love me welcome. <laugh>
um, as you may have heard this summer,
there were allegations of a toxic work environment at our show.
And then there was an investigative.
I learned that things happened here that never should have happened.
I take that very seriously. And I wanna say,
I am so sorry to the people who were affected.
I know that I'm in a position of privilege and power,
and I realize that with that comes responsibility and I take responsibility for
what happens at my show. Just wanna give.
A quick shout out to uncle Ben. You a real one.
Uncle Ben Spiderman. <laugh>
am I wrong? Did you not just plagiarize? My man,
uncle Ben with great power comes great responsibility.
I didn't even see that thing, man, but yeah,
that's with great power comes great responsibility.
That's one of the most defining lines of my childhood. That's that's uncle Ben.
Yeah. That's uncle Ben. Yeah. As soon as I heard that,
I started looking at cops like yo,
you ain't heard uncle Ben <laugh> we investigator our with great power
comes. Great responsibility Mr. Law enforcement. Oh no. Okay.
Uncle. Yeah, uncle Bens. G I thought, I thought you was for two seconds.
I thought you was talking about rice, bro. So I'm not the only one.
Like what the hell is, are you hungry? Uncle Ben have to do with this.
I talking about spider radioactive Spiderman, Spiderman,
Spiderman, radio active,
man. I think we get it. Yo, that was the heat.
That was dope. It was fire. Yo Mary Jane was the hottest ginger. After that,
I started looking at redhead women to do same. This. I was like, yo,
why y'all out like Mary Jane hot. Then I saw the movies and I was like,
y'all done Mary Jane. Yeah. Get some day outta.
We have had a lot of conversations over the last few weeks about the show,
our workplace and what we want for the future.
We have made the necessary changes. And today we are starting a new chapter.
There were also articles in the press and on social media that said that I am
not who I appear to be on TV because I became known as the be kind lady.
The truth is I am that per that you see on TV.
I am also a lot of other things. I sometimes I get sad. I get mad. I,
I get anxious. I get frustrated. I get impatient.
And I am working on all of that. I am a work in progress.
What's wrong, man. What is it?
I feel like you just gas lit everybody who said that they had terrible
experiences working with you.
Mm it's not enough for you to just sit there and be like,
I'm a work in progress.
If you don't acknowledge the negative things that you've done,
did you up yes or no. Say that you messed up and say how don't be like,
I'm a work in pro and I'll I'll do better. That's doesn't explain anything.
Right? You kind of just be like, well, you know the reason I'm to be kind, it,
it, it,
the reason why people are on you and they call you a hypocrite is because you
espe this idea of being kind,
but your behavior was completely the opposite to a lot of people who had less
power than you. It's easy to say. Be kind.
What is difficult is to be kind to people who can't take anything away from you.
Right. That's the test of character.
And so I just kind of find it very slimy and well it's calculated.
It's tactical. Yeah. We're all just growing we're yeah. Everyone's growing.
But do you, haven't taken accountability.
It doesn't look like from anything that you're saying, but whatever.
And I'm especially working on the impatience thing because,
and it's not going well because it's not happening fast enough.
I will tell you that <laugh> listen. You know, I,
I don't know. I I'm a talk show host and you know that, but I,
maybe some of you know that, you know, I was an actress.
I've played a straight woman in movies, so I'm a pretty good actress.
<laugh> but I don't think that I'm that good that I could come out here every
day for 17 years and fool you. This is me.
And my intention is to always be the best person I can be.
And if I've ever let someone down, if I've ever hurt their feelings,
I am so sorry for that.
Okay. I got a problem right there. So this is me. This is me. Well,
what you're displaying right? There is not the problem. Ellen,
what people have a problem is how you are backstage.
It's just things you do when the cameras aren't on.
So when you say this is me, this is me. Well,
it sounds again like you're gaslighting,
the very people who said that backstage,
you mistreated them because it's not about how you are in front of the cameras.
And it's also you. Yes, it is. You, it, it is you. It is part of you,
but anybody that is bad and bad at something or bad to people are
good to other people. So yes, the good part is,
is also them. But it's not what we're talking about. Yeah.
Hitler had a family, Hitler had a family, he had nieces,
uncles and stuff like that. And it was probably good to them. Yeah.
But he was still Hitler to the rest of the people.
But you don't think a Nazi in Christmas party was, was, was, was lit. Come on.
Be, I'm not saying, and I'm not saying, are we comparing you to Hitler?
Although, you know, blue eyes, blonde hair, see, I made a joke there.
You don't like that. Yeah. Well that's what.
So my hope is that we can still be a place of happiness and joy.
I still wanna be the one hour a day that people can go to escape and laugh.
I wanna continue to help all the people that we help every day.
And I'm committed to making the best season that we have ever had.
Problem that I have with the apology is this.
Cause I understand that people can do to mess.
They can mess up because of character and realize that they mess up and then
apologize and become better.
And I understand that the problem is you, the way you phrase it,
it really sounds like, you know, oh, well, you know, I'm, I,
I just want people to, to,
to feel good about this show and then be the one hour day that people escape.
That was not the problem. Again, that was not the problem. That one hour,
a day that you did in front of people was not the problem.
That was not the issue.
When you did that thing in front of people and you made them,
you still made them laugh. But the problem was back there.
The other people that made the show that that's the,
that's the problem that that happened.
And that's what the issue is with the allegations that were against you.
Not the show, not the one hour that you were on camera and you keep on refr,
like refrain to that and everything and stuff. Anyways,
the thing that I wanted to say is this, all right,
it's very calculated and tactical, of course she's on TV. And that's what it is.
There's people working on that you have to understand that everything is
calculated to what, from what she's saying to the angles, to what she's wearing,
the why, I'm not saying that she's not sincere about what it is,
but I understand because I work in the industry, that all it is is tactical.
The fact that she's wearing white on white,
on white being a white lady doing that is calculated. She has,
she can't doing that apology wearing red,
looking like the devil <laugh> that can't happen.
You understand what I'm saying? So I understand that everything is calculated,
but you still, again, the fact that you're, Rero the, the conversation,
the allegation that happens against you to that the show and the one hour
that you were good again, makes me feel like, yeah,
you were you're you're you're dodging and you're reflecting. You're deflecting.
What the issue was initially.
Um, I love you so much. I am so happy to, to,
to announce that you're not my DJ anymore. Right? Right. You are now,
can we get a drum roll? Is that possible? Oh, look at that.
<Laugh>.
My co-executive producer.
Are you serious? It's been in the news before that. I don't even know. Yeah.
Yeah. He's the co-executive uh, producer now. Yeah, absolutely.
Why a long faith. I mean,
he was by her side when yo at,
at the height of all this civil unrest movement,
this just seems like a great PR point just saying,
have a black man promoted as your executive. I like,
I like to see a black man get paid, but like I, I said before,
all of this is tactical. This should have been your apology. I up. I'm sorry.
I really need to do better.
We've been saying that all these other things about apologies and this and that,
man y'all know what they do. They stuck out the same script.
You have to understand actually, just to,
to reinforce the fact that you think that it's like a, uh, what I, of her,
you know, the fact that he put TWI as a you and your apology,
not this show your apology by that announcement.
I'm so progressive. It's, it's tactical. It's very, self-serving it's tactical.
And I understand, again, I'm not saying that she doesn't feel what she feels,
but all of that is it's very calculated, which you know,
it is what it is and that's the business.
But people when it's like those people in those abusive relationships,
mm-hmm <affirmative> right. And then they like, right. I changed I've changed.
And then you finish with a bouquet. It it's it's it's I, I get it.
I, I get it. I really get it.
And Twitch was not one of 'em that was suffering because it was part of,
you know, the team team right off it that's different people, you know
me, listen. Um, that's just me. That's just me. I try to be nice.
I'm I'm I'm not, I don't try to be nice. I'm nice to everybody. I meet.
If I go to culinary's club, whatever, whatnot. Cause I can understand.
I can go back to that stage real quick. All of this can end really quick.
So, but yeah, all that was tactical,
all that was tactical, it was, it was really tactical. Like I said,
the measure of character is not how you treat people in front of the cameras,
but it's how you treat people who have zero ability to hurt
you or to give you something or to promote you when you, yeah.
Anyone who you don't need anything from rough.
Those are the people who I judge you on and how you interact with them.
And so far your track record been negative. You didn't address that.
So your apology and all this other Raff about love is important and blah, blah,
blah. You know what love is founded on honesty and integrity and you lack it.
So here you preach about love and this and the boo boo.
No, nah. It's no for me, dog.
You.